[Music]
all right
so let's let's kick things off here
with just a simple introductory question
so could you give us a little bit of
background about silver lining
and and what is its mission
sure lucas and i want to start by thank
you for inviting me
to talk with you and your community
because the issue of existential threats
is not an easy one
and so our approach at silver lining i
think overlaps with some of the kinds of
dialogue that you're having
where we're really concerned about this
sort of catastrophic risks that we may
have
with regards to climate change in the
next 10 to 30 years
so silver lining was started
specifically to focus on near-term
climate risk
and the uncertainties we have about
climate system instability
runaway climate change and the kinds of
things we don't have
insurance policies against yet so
my background is from the technology
sector i worked in areas of complex
systems analysis
in it infrastructure and so i came into
this problem
looking at it primarily from a risk
point of view
and the fact that the kind of risk that
we have
that we currently have exposure to is is
an unacceptable one
and so we need to expand our toolkit and
our portfolio
until we've got sufficient options in
there
that we can address the different kinds
of risks that we're facing in the
context of of the climate situation
so silver lining is a two-year-old
organization and
uh there are two things that we do we we
look at policy
and sort of driving how in particular
these
interventions and climate these things
that might help reduce warming or cool
the planet quickly
how we might move those forward in terms
of research and assessment from a policy
perspective
and then how we might actually help
drive research and technology innovation
directly and so we do both of those
things okay so
the the the methods of intervention are
policy
and um uh like research
so our methods of operation are policy
research the methods of intervention in
particular that i'm referring to
are these sort of technologies and
approaches for directly
um and rapidly reducing warming
in the climate system yeah so i i was
also a bit surprised that he
so so in what you just said you
mentioned that
um you're concerned about uh
catastrophic risks from from climate
change for example
in the next 10 to 30 years um could you
paint us a little bit of a picture about
why that kind of time scale
is is relevant i think many people and
myself included might
might have thought that the more
significant changes would
would take longer than 10 to 30 years so
what is the general
like state of of the climate now and
where we're heading in in the next few
decades
um well so so i think there are a couple
of key issues
in sort of the evolution of climate
change and and what to expect and how
they think about risk
one is that the projections that we have
you know are it's a tough type of system
and a tough type of situation to project
and predict
and there are some things that climate
modelers and climate scientists
know are not adequately represented
in our forecasts and projections so a
lot of the projections we've had the
past 10 or 15 years talk about climate
change through 2100
and we see these sort of smooth curves
of
you know depending on how we manage
greenhouse gases we've got these smooth
curves
but people who are familiar with the
climate system itself or
complex type systems problems know
that there are these non-linear events
that are likely to happen
and right now in climate models they
have a very difficult time representing
those
so in many cases they're either sort of
roughly represented or or excluded
entirely
and those are the things that we've that
we talk about in terms of
abrupt change and tipping points so our
kind of model projections are actually
missing or under representing tipping
points things like the release
of greenhouse gases from permafrost that
could happen suddenly and very quickly
as
as the surface melts things like the
collapse of big ice sheets and
on downstream effects of that so one of
the concerns that we have in silver
lining
is that some of the things that tech
people know how to do
it's a similar problem to manage an i.t
network it's a highly complex systems
problem where you're trying to maintain
a stable state of the network
and some of the techniques that we use
for doing that have not been fully
applied
to looking at the climate problem and
similarly some of the similar techniques
we use in finance
one of our advisors is the former
director of global research at goldman
sachs
and this is a problem we're talking to
him about and folks in the ipcc
and other places about you know
essentially
we need um some new and different types
of analysis plot applied to this problem
beyond just what the climate models do
right and so so so problem number one is
that our analytic techniques are
underrepresenting
the risk and particularly potentially
risk in the near term the the second
piece
is that these abrupt climate changes
tend to be highly
highly related to what they call uh
feedbacks
meaning that there are points at which
these climate changes
produce effects that that either put
warming back in the system or
greenhouse gases back in the system or
both
and once that starts to happen the
problem could get away from us
in terms of our ability to respond now
we might not know whether that risk
is you know 5 10 or 80 percent
from silver linings perspective from my
perspective perspective any meaningful
risk of that
in the next 10 to 30 years is an
unacceptable level of risk
because it's it's approaching you know
somewhere between catastrophic and
they're existential
and so we're less concerned about the
arm wrestle debate over
you know well is there some scenario
where we can constrain the system by
just reducing greenhouse gases
we're concerned about are there
scenarios where
that doesn't work yeah and it hears that
there's a meaningful probability
that there are scenarios where the
system moves faster
than we can constrain greenhouse gases
and the plan the final thing i'll say is
that we're seeing evidence of that now
so some of the things that we're seeing
like these
these extraordinaries of wildfire events
what's happening to the ice sheets these
are things that are happening
at the far end of bad predictions
so they're happening the observations of
what's happening in the system
are indicative of the fact that that
risk could be pretty high
yeah so yeah so you're ending here on
the point that say the
fires that we're observing more recently
are like showing that tail end risks are
becoming more common
and so they're less like tail end risks
and more like becoming part of the
central mass of the the gaussian curve
um okay and and so i i want to slow down
a little bit because i think we
introduced uh a bunch of like crucial
concepts here
um so if you were to so so one of these
is like tipping points
so if you were to explain tipping points
and like
one to two sentences to to to someone
who's not familiar with with climate
science how would you do that
well the the metaphor that i like to use
is similar to a fever in the human body
and so warming heat acts as a stressor
on the system on different parts of the
system so when you have a fever
you can carry a fever up to a certain
point and if it gets high enough and
long enough
different parts of your body will be
affected like your brain
your organs and so on and so uh
the trapped heat energy in the climate
system acts as a stressor
on different parts of the system and
they can warm a bit
over a certain period of time and
they're and
they'll recover kind of their original
state but beyond a certain point
essentially the conditions of heat that
they're in
are sufficiently different than what
they're used to
that they start to fundamentally change
and that can happen in biological
systems where you start to lose animal
species
plant species that can happen in
physical systems where the structure of
an ice sheet
starts to disintegrate and once that
structure breaks down
it doesn't come back forests have this
quality
too where if they get hot enough and dry
enough
then they they may pass a point where
they're
where their operation as a forest no
longer works
and they collapse into something else
like
desertification right and so so that so
there are two concerns with that one is
that we lose these big systems
permanently because they change a state
in a way that doesn't
recover and the second is that when they
do that
they either add warming or add
greenhouse gases back into the system
as well so when an isc collapse for
example these big
um these big ice structures they reflect
a huge amount of sunlight back out to
space
and when we lose them they're replaced
by dark water
and so that's basically a trade-off from
cooling to warming
that's happening with ice and so there
are different things like that where
that combination of losing that system
and then having it really change the
balance of warming
is a you know double faceted problem
right so it's like you have these these
dynamic systems which play
an integral part in maintaining the
current climate stability
and they can undergo like a phase
a phase state change like like water is
water
until you hit a certain degree and then
it turns into ice or into
it evaporates and turns into steam
except you can't go back easily
um with these kinds of systems um
and you know once it changes it it
throws off the whole
like more dynamic context that it's that
it's in that's
stabilizing the the environment as we
enjoy it
um
and i can throw out the picture for you
yeah
um this comes from will stefan who is
one of the fathers of earth system
science and so
one of the problems that you have is not
just that any one of these systems might
change its state
and might start putting warming or
greenhouse gases back in
into the atmosphere but they're linked
to each other
and so then they call that the cascade
effect
where one system changes its state and
that pushes another system over the edge
and that pushes another system over the
edge and so
you know so a collapse of ice sheets can
actually accelerate the collapse of the
amazon rainforest
for example through this process
so it's a and that's where we you know
we come more towards the sort of
existential category where
we don't we don't want to come anywhere
near that risk if we can help it
and we're dangerously near it if not
having some of these things start to
happen already
and so in um well i was trying to move
this forward but
um and so one of the problems that
you know scientists like will steffen
and some arctic scientists for example
are seeing is that some of these tipping
points they think we're
in and i've heard i work with climate
scientists really closely and i hear
them saying
you know we may be in it meaning that
some of these tipping points are
starting to occur
and so the ice ones you know we have
front page news
on that today on the forest ones we're
starting to see
and so so that's where the concern
becomes that we
sort of lack the measures to address
these things if they're happening in the
next
you know one two or three decades
yeah so so we have um
sorry um so we have tipping points
which are you know
like we have dynamic systems which help
to maintain the current state
uh like the equilibrium of the
environment um
and these um these like dynamic
environments like you just mentioned a
bunch of them
um like the the ice caps and like the
amazon rainforest and all these things
um they can undergo tipping points where
they are
irreversibly changed or not irreversibly
changed but
it's good it would it's would take way
more energy and effort to
put them back the way that they were um
and then that leads to tipping cascades
um where the failure of one system can
lead to the it can act as a catalyst for
the
for the failing or further systems um
and then
this becomes i don't know is is this
where a word like
runaway climate change becomes relevant
yes um and so when when i came into the
space like 12 years ago
and for many of your listeners i came in
from tech first as a sort of
area of passion interest and one of the
first people i talked to was a climate
scientist named steve schneider
who was at stanford at the time and he's
since passed away but he was a giant of
the field
and i asked him kind of the question
you're referring to which is how would
you characterize the odds of runaway
change within our lifetime
and he said at that time which was about
12 years ago
he said i put it in the single digits
but not the low single digits
and my reaction to that was you know if
you had those odds of winning the
lottery you'd be out buying tickets
yeah and if we had an eight to ten
percent chance of an asteroid hitting
the planet we'd be building the giant
laser array
and that's an unacceptable level of risk
where we don't have responses that
really meaningfully arrest or reduce
warming in that kind of time
right okay and so
uh another point here is you you've used
the word existential a few times here
um and you've also used the word global
catastrophic
um now i think broadly within the
existential risk community at least like
the
place where i come from climate change
is not viewed as an existential risk
like even if it gets really really
really bad it's hard to imagine
ways in which it would kill all people
on the planet rather than like make life
very difficult for most of them and kill
like large fractions and so it's
generally viewed as a global
catastrophic threat
being that it would kill large fractions
but not be existential
uh what what is your reaction to that
and um
how do you view the use of the word
existential here
um well so for me there are two sides to
that question
and i normally stay on one of the two
sides which is
really about for silver lining our
mission is to prevent suffering
and so the loss of you know a third of
the population of the planet
or two-thirds of the population of the
planet
and the survival of some people in
interconnected bubbles which i've heard
top analysts talk about for us that's
unacceptable
that's an unacceptable level of
suffering and an unacceptable outcome
and so um in that way
you know we the debate about whether
it's all people or just
lots of people is for us not
that material because that whole
situation
seems to be you know not a risk that you
want to take
in in the sense in in the other side of
your question whether
is it all people and is it like
planetary livability
i think that question is subject to this
some of the under um the
the in the inability to fully represent
all of the all of the systemic effects
that happen at these levels of warming
and um i you know
early on when i talked about this with
the director of nasa ames at the time
who's not at planet labs what he talked
to me about was the changes in chemistry
of the earth system and so
you know this is something that it
hasn't maybe been explored that widely
but we're already looking at collapses
of life in the ocean and
between the ocean and the you know the
land systems that generates a lot of the
sort of atmosphere that we're familiar
with and that's comfortable for people
and there are risks to that that we
can't have these collapses of biological
life
and necessarily maintain the atmosphere
that we're used to
and so i think that again i'll say
that i think that it's inappropriate to
discount the possibility
that the planet could become largely
unlivable
at these higher levels of heat and that
in a runaway climate change scenario
where the heat levels get very high
and biological life collapses in an
extreme
way i don't think that's been analyzed
well enough yet
and i certainly wouldn't rule it out as
an existential risk i think that
that that would be inappropriate given
both our level of knowledge
and the fact that we know that we have
these sort of non-linear
cascading things going that are going to
happen
so to me i challenge the existential
direct community
to look into this further
put it out there cool
i like that um
[Music]
okay so so given given like tipping
points and
like cascading tipping points um
you you think there's a little bit more
uncertainty over how
how how unlivable things can get uh
i do and that's before you also get into
the societal part of it right
yeah yeah so how it can be the subset of
people that are left
yeah so i think it's you know i'm going
back to
what i think has been one of the
fundamental problems of the climate
debate is this idea that there are
winners and losers
and that this is a reasonably survivable
situation for a certain class of people
i think there's a reasonable probability
that that's not the case
and this is not going to be a world that
anyone if they do get to live in it
is going to enjoy yeah even if
even if you're if you were a billionaire
back before climate change and you have
your nice stocked bunker it's
uh new zealand yeah you can't keep
stocking it
uh your money won't be worth anything
um yeah and a world without strawberries
and lobsters and
you know rock concerts and all kinds of
things that we like
so i yeah so i think we're we're much
more in it together than people think
and that you know the humans were
you know over the course of many
millennia in engineered and fine-tuned
to this
beautiful extremely complicated system
that we live in
and we're pushing it you know we can use
our technology the best of our ability
to adapt
but really you know this
is this is an environment that's
beautifully made for us
and we're pushing it out of out of the
state that supports us
okay so um can you i'd be curious if you
could expand just uh
probably like fairly briefly here on i'm
curious to know
like more of the ways in which um these
these systems which help to maintain the
current climate status like function
so for example like the jet stream and
the boreal forest and the amazon
rainforest and the sahel
and the indian summer monsoon and the
permafrost and
all these other things um if you could
choose i don't know maybe
one or two of your favorites or
something or whichever
few are like biggest i i i'm curious how
these systems
like help continue to maintain the uh
like climate stability well
so you know there are people more expert
than me but i'll talk about a couple
that i care about a lot
so one is the is the permafrost which is
the frozen layer
of earth and that frozen layer of earth
is on the surface in land masses
and also frozen um layers under the
ocean
and so for for many thousands of years
if not longer
um those layers you know sort of they
capture and build up like the
biological life that's died and
sort of decayed within these frozen
layers of earth and stored massive
amounts
of carbon and so
provided the earth system is working you
know within its usual parameters
all of those masses stay frozen and that
organic material stays there
and so as it warms up in a way that it
moves beyond its normal sort of range of
parameters
then that stuff starts to melt and those
gases start to be released
and so that and the amount of gas
stored in the permafrost is massive
and particularly it includes both co2
and the
more the more dense uh
fast-acting gases like methane
and so that you know we're kind of
sitting on the edge of that system
starting to melt in a way where those
releases could be massive and in my work
that's
to me one of the things that we need to
watch most closely
because that that's a potential runaway
situation
so so that's one and that's a relatively
straightforward one because it's you
know systems storing greenhouse gases
releasing greenhouse gases um they run
you know they range in complexity like
the arctic is a much more complicated
one because it's related to all the
physics of the movement of the
atmosphere and ocean
so the circulation of the of the way the
jet stream and weather patterns work
the circulation of the ocean and all of
that so there could be
potential drastic effects on what
weather is where on the planet
if so major changes in the arctic can
lead to major changes in what we
experience as like our normal weather
yeah and we're already seeing this start
to happen in europe
and that was predicted by changes in the
jet stream where europe's always had
this kind of mild sort of temperate
range of temperature
and they're starting to see super cold
winters and hot summers
and that's because the jet stream is
moving i see
and a lot of that is because the arctic
is small team
okay so i can give you another one if
you want
yeah i mean my my a personal
you know personal one that's um you know
that's dear to me and
it is actually happening now and we may
not be able to stop no matter what what
we do
are the coral reefs and so
you know coral reefs are these organic
structures and they team with all
different
levels of life and they trace up to
about a quarter of all life in the ocean
so as these coral reefs are getting hit
by these
waves of hot water they're dying
and ultimately they're collapsing in the
collapse of at least
25 percent of life in the ocean that
they support
and we don't really know fully what the
effects of that will be
so those are a few examples i see so the
hot waters
i feel like i've heard the word heat
stress before in relation to coral reefs
and then that's what kills it
yeah they don't like functioning and
they can't function in hot water
um all right so before we move
we we move into here into your specific
proposed you know the area you're
interested in
in uh intervening as a potential
solution
if we can't get the greenhouse gases
down enough
um are there any more bad things that we
missed or
bad things that would happen if we don't
sufficiently
get climate change under control so i
think that
um there are many um
and we haven't talked too much about
what happens on the human side
so there are even thresholds of of
direct heat for humans
you know you've you've heard about this
before like the hot bulb temperature
the what sorry the hot bulb temperature
i have not heard that the outdoor heat
threshold for
for people okay and
i i'm not gonna be able to describe it
super expertly but
the combination of heat humid and
humidity at which
the human body changes the way it
um it's it's sort of expiring
um heat and
um and sort of
that heat exchange and so what's
happening in certain parts of the world
right now
like in india in parts of india like
calcutta
there's an increasing number of days of
the year where it's not safe to work
outside
and there are some projections that by
2030 there would be no days in calcutta
where it was safe to work outside
and so the issue it becomes and we're
and we even see parts of the u.s where
you have these heat warnings
and right now as a as a direct effect on
humans
i i just saw a study that said the
actual
the actual heat index is killing more
people than than the smoke from fires
and so the the actual increase in heat
is moving past where humans are actually
comfortable living and interacting
now as as a secondary point obviously in
developed countries we have lots of
tools for dealing with that in terms of
our you know infrastructure but one of
the things that's happening
is our infrastruct the the system is
moving outside the band in which our
infrastructure was built
and and this is a bit of an understudied
area
in terms of you know as warming
progresses
and you have extreme temperature you
have more flooding you have extreme
storms and winds
we have everything from bridges to
nuclear plants
to skyscrapers that were not engineered
for those conditions
they're moving outside the conditions
that our infrastructure was built to
and so you know full evaluation of that
is not really uh available to us
yet and so i think we're we may be
underestimating even things like okay
in some of these projections we know
that as sea level rise happens and
extreme storms happen
places like miami are probably lost
and in that context what does it mean to
have a city the size of miami
sitting under water at the edge of the
united states it would be a massive
environmental catastrophe just that
yeah so i think we've you know i think
unfortunately
like we haven't looked closely enough at
what it means for all of these parts of
our like human infrastructure
you know for for for their their
external circumstances to be outside the
arena that they were engineered for
yeah so natural systems become stressed
they become to fail there could be
cascades
human systems and human infrastructure
becomes
like getting stressed i mean you can
imagine like
nuclear facilities and oil rigs and
whatever else can cause massive
environmental damage
getting stressed as well by being moved
outside the normal bandwidth of
operation
um so it just seems it's like it's just
a lot of bad things happening after bad
things after
bad things um yeah
yeah and and you know a big problem
because i've had this debate with people
who are bullish on
adaptation that you know hey we can
adapt to this and
but the problem is you have all these
things happening concurrently
you know they're happening at the same
time so it's not just miami
it's miami and san francisco and
bangladesh
you know it's how it's going to be
happening lots of different variants of
it
happening all in all at the same time
and so anything we can do to prevent
that
you know excuse my academic language
should show
is really something we should consider
closely
and invest in closely because the cost
of that and the sort of compound damage
is just
it it's it's pretty staggering yeah it's
often much cheaper to prevent risks than
to
than to deal with them when they come up
and then clean up the aftermath
so um as we try to avoid
you know moderate to severe whatever bad
effects of climate change we can we can
mitigate um
i think i mean i think most everyone is
very familiar with
the idea of reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
so the kinds of gases that help trap
heat
inside of the atmosphere um now
you're coming at this from a different
angle so what is your what is
what is the research interest of silver
lining and
um what is the intervention
of mitigating some of the effects of
climate change
yeah what is that intervention that you
guys are exploring
well so our interest is um in
in the near-term risk and so therefore
we focus most closely on things that
might
have the potential to act quickly to
substantially reduce warming in the
climate system
and the problem with greenhouse gas
reduction
and a lot of the categories of emerging
category of
of removing greenhouse gases from the
air
are that you know they take they're
likely to take many decades to scale
and even longer to actually act on the
climate system
and so if we're looking at sub 30 years
where we're coming from in silver lining
is saying um
we don't have enough in that portfolio
to
make sure that we can keep the system
stable and so we're um
i'm going to share my screen with you
again we are um
a science-led organization meaning we we
don't do
research ourselves but we follow the
recommendations of the scientific
community and the scientific assessment
bodies
and in 2015 the national academy of
sciences in the united states
they ran an assessment that looked at
the different sort of technological
interventions
that might be used to accelerate
addressing
climate warming and greenhouse gases
and they issued two reports on one
called climate intervention carbon
dioxide removal
and one called climate intervention
reflecting sunlight to cool
earth and what they found was that
in the category where you're looking to
reduce warming quickly
within a decade or even a few years
that the most promising way to try to do
that is based on one of the ways that
the earth system actually regulates
temperature which is the reflection of
sunlight from particles and clouds in
the atmosphere
so that's what you're seeing here is a
simulation from nasa
of the movement of clouds and particles
in the atmosphere and
and the reflection of some light and the
theories behind why they think this
might work
are based on observations from the real
world
and so what i'm showing you right now is
a picture of
um a cloud bank off the pacific west
coast and the streaks in the clouds are
created by
emissions from ships and so
uh the particulates in those emissions
usually what people think of as the
dirty stuff
has a property where it often mixes with
clouds in a way
that will make the cloud slightly
brighter
and so based on that effect um
scientists think that there's cooling
that could be generated in this way
actively and also that there's actually
cooling going on right now
as a result of the particulate effects
of our emissions
overall and they think that we have this
accidental cooling going
on somewhere between 0.5 degrees and 1.1
degrees c
and this is something that they don't
understand very well
but is potentially uh both a promise and
a risk
when it comes to climate so
so this approach um
is can we go back for a second sure
yeah so yeah so
like the so there's like some there's
some amount of cooling that's going on
by by accident but the the last the last
gra
the last bar is showing that the the net
anthropogenic
uh heating is positive even with the
cooling
and um i think one facet of this that i
learned from looking into your work
is that uh the the the cooling effect is
limited because the particles fall back
down
and so it goes away and so there might
be like in a period of acceleration
of the of the heat is that right
so yeah yes i think what you're getting
at
um so two things i'll say these these
white lines
sort of spider lines indicate the
uncertainty
and so you can see the biggest line is
on that cloud albedo effect
which is how much do these particles
brighten clouds and so the effect could
be much bigger
than what's going into that net effect
bar where
and a lot of the uncertainty in that net
effect bar is coming from that one thing
so um oh coming from whether or not they
fall
coming from this cloud albedo effect the
uncertainty
of what is that magnitude of the effect
now the fact that they fall is an issue
but what happens today for the most part
is we keep putting them up there
and so as long as you continuously put
them up there you continuously have this
effect
if you take it away that's the next
picture
which we're doing a couple of big
experiments in this year
then you lose that cooling effect right
away
and so one of the things that we're
we're hoping
to help with is getting more money for
research to look at
two big events that took that away this
year
one is the the economic shutdowns
associated with coven
where we had these clean skies all over
the world because all this pollution
went down and so that's a big
you know global experiment in removing
these particles
that may be cooling and so
we are hoping to to to get gain a better
understanding from that experiment
if we can get enough resources for
people to look at it well
so the the uncertainty with how much
like the degree to which current
pollution is
reflecting sunlight is that because we
have uncertainty over
like exactly how much pollution there is
and how much
sunlight that is exactly reflecting
given the
like given the amount of do we just not
know how much like a certain size
cloud reflects sunlight it's actually
it's not that we don't know how much
pollution there is i think we know that
pretty well
it's that this interaction between
clouds and particles
is one of the biggest uncertainties in
the climate system
and there's a natural form of it like
when you see salt spray generating
clouds like you're in big sur looking at
the waves and the clouds starting to
form
um that that whole process is highly
complex
clouds are among the most complex um
creatures
in our uh earth system
and so and they're based on the behavior
of these tiny particles that attract
water to them
and then create different sizes of
droplets so
if the droplets are big they reflect
less total sunlight off less total
surface area and you have a dark cloud
and eventually the drops droplets are
big enough they fall down as rain
if the droplets are small there's lots
of surface area
and they the cloud becomes brighter and
so the pro
the reason we have that uncertainty is
that we have uncertainty around the
whole process
and some of the scientists that we work
with in silver lining they really want
to focus on that
because understanding that process will
tell you what you might be able to do
with that artificially
to create a brightening effect on
purpose as well as how much of an
accidental effect we've got going on
okay and good
well you go ahead and then yeah sorry
the last thing was just
um so you you're saying we're removing
sulfate from the emission of ships and
sulfate is helping to create these
these sea clouds that are reflecting
sunlight
that's right and it happens over it
happens over land as well
right so it's all all the emissions that
contain these sulfate and similar types
of particles
can have this property and so that plus
the reduction of emissions is given the
the reduction of pollution given
kovid there is this ongoing experiment
accident an accidental experiment to to
decrease the amount of
reflective uh
yeah that's that's right and i should
just know that um the other thing that
happened in 2020
is that the international maritime
organization
implemented regulations to drastically
reduce emissions from
ships and so those went into effect in
january
an 85 percent reduction in these sulfate
emissions
and so that's the other experiment
because sulfate
because sulfate and these emissions we
don't like as pollutants
for human health for local ecosystems
they're dirty
they're really vile so we don't like
them for very good reasons
but they happen to have the side effect
of of
producing a brightening effect on clouds
and that that's the piece we want to
understand better
okay happy to move on
um yeah when i talk to especially people
um in in the bay area and and
you know people who think about systems
about this particular dynamic
most of the people that i've talked to
are unfamiliar with this
um and lots of people even who think
about climate a lot are unfamiliar with
the fact that we have this accidental
cooling going
on and that as we reduce emissions we
have this uncertain
near-term warming that may result from
that which i think is what you were
getting at
yeah yeah yeah so
okay um
[Music]
yeah let's let's let's keep going so
so where i'm headed with this is that um
in the early 90s some british
researchers proposed
that you might be able to produce a an
optimized
version of this effect using sea salt
particles like a salt mist from seawater
which would be cleaner and possibly
actually produce a stronger effect
because of the
nature of the salt particles and that
you could
target this at areas of unpolluted
clouds in certain parts of the ocean
where they'd be most susceptible and
you'd get this
highly magnified reflective effect
and that in doing that in
these sort of few parts of the world
where it would work
best by brightening 10 to 20
of of marine clouds or say the
equivalent of three to five percent of
the ocean's surface
you might offset a doubling of co2 or
several degrees of warming
by doing this and so that's
one approach to this kind of um
rapid cooling if you like that
um that scientists are thinking about
that's related to an observed effect
and so this quality or this marine cloud
brightening approach
um has the characteristic that you
talked about that is
relatively temporary so you have to do
it continuously
lasts a few days and otherwise if you
stop it stops
and it's also relatively localized so it
opens up theoretical possibilities
that um that you that you might consider
it as a way of
cooling ocean water and mitigating
climate impacts regionally or locally
like we would we would put some of these
missed
generators like off the
in i don't know where the hurricanes
are generated that slam into the
southeast coast of america all the
time like off the coast of africa but we
could let's put some like somewhere over
there and we would get less hurricanes
or something like that yeah so the
picture that i'm showing you is the gulf
atlantic and like one part of where the
hurricanes form
or traverse and so what you in theory
what you might do
is you know engage in this technique in
the months before hurricane season
so your goal is to cool the ocean
surface temperatures which are a big
part of what increases the
energy and the um
and the rainfall potential of storms
so this idea is very theoretical there's
been almost no research in it
yeah and similarly
there's a little bit of emerging
research and similar idea
could you cool waters that flow onto
coral reefs
and you might have to do this in areas
that are far further out from the coral
reefs because coral reefs tend to be in
places where there are no clouds
but your goal is to try to get you know
get those big currents of water that are
flowing on and cool them off
and so there was a little test very
little test tiny little test
of the technology that you might use
down in australia
as part of their um big program i think
it's an 800 million
program to look at all possibilities for
saving the great barrier reef
okay um what one thing that i think is
interesting for you to comment on
briefly
is um i think many people and myself
included don't really have like a good
intuition
about how thick the atmosphere is like
some people like you look up and it's
just like
big open space like maybe it goes on
forever or something
um and there's there's not really an
intuitive sense of like how big the sky
is or like how thick the
the atmosphere is um so like how thick
is it
and how is it that you know i mean
you put it into scale so it makes sense
that like seven billion
humans could could affect it
in such in such like large scale ways um
we're going to talk about it a little
bit differently because we're taught
um because the things i'm talking to you
about are different layers of the
atmosphere
that try to wear so the idea that i
talked to you about here a marine called
brightening
um that that's really looking at
the troposphere which is the lowest
layer of the atmosphere which are when
you look up these are the clouds i see
um and they're the it's the cloud layer
that's closest to earth going from
sort of like 500 feet up to a couple
thousand feet
and so um and so in that layer you may
have the possibility
of especially over the ocean of
generating a mist from the surface
where the convection like the the motion
of the air above you kind of pulls the
particles up into the cloud layer
and so you can do this kind of activity
potentially from the surface like from
ships
yeah so what is what go ahead sorry
finish and it's why the pollution
particles are getting sucked up into the
clouds too
okay yeah and so like what is that in
miles like that's not even
uh yeah that sounds like that sub mile
right yeah um that's still just just a
mile i would say i think maybe
um and so so that
so that idea you know happens at that
low layer submile layer
visible eye layer yeah of stuff
um and for the most part what's being
proposed
in terms of like volume of material or
the like when scientists are talking
about brightening these clouds they're
talking about brightening them
five to seven percent so it's not
something that you would probably see
as a human with your own naked eyes and
it's also over the ocean
and it's over the ocean and it's
something that would have a
a relatively modest effect on you know
the light
coming into the ocean below so probably
a relatively modest effect on the like
local ecology
except for the cooling that it's created
so um so in that way it's you know
potentially less invasive than people
might think
um just to veer off a little bit from
your question
where the risks are because i think it's
related to your question
where the risks are in a technique like
this are really around the fact that
you're creating these sort of
concentrated
areas of cooling and those have the
potential to move the circulation
of the atmosphere and change weather
patterns
in ways that are hard to predict
and that's probably the biggest thing
that people are concerned about with
this idea
now if you'd like i can talk about what
people are proposing at the other side
the the high end of the of the
atmosphere
yeah so i was about to ask you about
stratospheric sunlight reflection
um so go go for that yeah because this
is the one that most people
have who've heard about this have heard
about
and it's the most kind of widely studied
and talked about
partly because it's based on uh events
that have occurred in nature and
so whoops um am i so when mount
peniteubo erupted in 1991
large volcanoes push material into the
atmosphere and very large ones can push
material all the way into the outer
layer of the atmosphere
the stratosphere which i think starts at
about 30 or 40 thousand feet
and goes up for a few miles so
when particles reach the stratosphere
they get entrained and they can stay
for a year or two and when mount
pinatubo erupted in 1991
it was powerful and it pushed particles
into the stratosphere that stayed there
for
almost two years and it produced a
measuring
measurable cooling effect in the entire
planet of at least a half a degree
c actually popped up closer to one
degree c
and so this cooling effect was sustained
it was very clear and measurable
it lasted until the particles fell down
to earth
and it also produced a marked change
in arctic ice so this is a graph
that shows um arctic ice mass
starting in the late 80s and
going up till now and you can see this
sort of pop
in a year after penitubo where arctic
ice mass just recovered drastically
and so this um cooling effect
where the particles reach the
stratosphere they immediately or
very quickly get dispersed globally so
it's a global effect
um but it may have an outside effect
on the arctic um which warms and cools
faster than the rest of the planet
based on what's going on so this
this idea um and there are some other
examples in the volcanic record
is what led scientists including the
nobel prize winning scientist
who um who identified the ozone hole
paul kreutzen to suggest that one
you know one approach to offsetting the
warming that's happening with climate
change would be to introduce particles
in the stratosphere
that reflects sunlight directly almost
kind of like bedazzling the stratosphere
um and that by increasing this
reflectivity by just
one percent that you could offset a
doubling of co2
or several degrees of warming
now the particles that volcanoes release
in this way are similar to the pollution
particles on the ground there are
sulfates
and they're precursors and so
these particles also have the property
where they can damage the ozone layer
and they can also cause the stratosphere
itself to heat up
and so that introduces risks that we
don't understand very well
yeah and so that you know
so so that's what what people want to
study
um but one thing i'll show you and i'll
i'll i'll let you throw some questions
at me lucas
is um there isn't very much research on
this yet
but one of the earliest models was
produced at ncar
that modeled the compared the course
of global surface temperatures
in a business as usual scenario in the
end car global climate model
versus introducing particles into the
stratosphere
starting in 2020 gradually increasing
them
and maintaining temperatures through the
end of the century
and what you can see in that model
representation is that it's
theoretically possible to keep global
surface temperatures close to those of
today
with this technique and that if we were
to go down this
business's usual path um or have
higher than expected feedbacks that took
us to something similar
that that's not a very livable situation
um for most people on the planet
all right so let's so okay so we have
um sorry what is the the
the level the atmosphere that we live in
called again
uh well so the one on the left is called
business as usual
no no sorry i'm asking you a different
question uh the the place where we're
trying to make clouds what is that
called
the troposphere uh the troposphere okay
so they're in
yeah so you can you can intervene um
you can intervene in the troposphere or
the the the stratosphere yeah
yes um and so these are the two
interventions that
the the that there's like a ha ha
there's a large degree of
uncertainty about like indirect effects
and second
and third order effects of these
interventions right
so they need to be studied because
you're impacting a complex system which
may have
complex implications in different
degrees
of like um
[Music]
at different levels of causality um
but but so like the the high level
like strategy here is that these these
things may be necessary
if we're not able to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions sufficiently
and so
that's why we may be interested in it
for mitigating some degree
of climate change that that happens or
is inevitable
um that's right there's a there's a
slight sort of
twist on that i think where um
it's really about if we can
trying to look at these um dangerous
instabilities
and intervene before they happen
or before they take us across thresholds
we don't want to go
so it's it is what you're saying
um but it's a little bit of a different
shade where we don't wait to see how our
mitigation is of effort is going
necessarily
what we need to do is watch the earth
system
and see whether we're reaching kind of a
red zone
where we've got to bring the heat down
in the system
okay all right um
and so
what kinds of ongoing experiments are
happening
um for studying these these these two
kinds of
um interventions in
in climate change the yeah the
tropospheric and stratospheric
well so the first thing we'll say is
that um
the research in this field has been very
taboo
for most of you know the past few
decades
so relative to the problem space very
little research has been done
okay and the global level of investment
in research even today is probably in
the neighborhood of 10 million
a year and that includes a three million
dollar a year program in china
and um a program at harvard which is
really the
the biggest funded program in the world
so
relative to you know the problem space
and the potential we're very
underinvested
and the things i'm going to talk to you
about are really promising and there are
prestigious
institutions and collaborations but
they're still
at what i would call a very seed level
of funding um
and so that's you know that's what i'll
say
so that the two kind of um
[Music]
most significant interdisciplinary
programs
in the field one is
aimed at the stratosphere and that's a
program at harvard
which is an interdisciplinary program
called the harvard solar geo engineering
program
and includes social science and and
physical sciences but
uh a sort of flagship of what they're
trying to do
is to do an experiment in the
stratosphere um
and in their case they would try to use
a balloon which is specially crafted to
navigate in the stratosphere
which is a hard problem so that they can
do releases
of different materials to look at their
properties
in the stratosphere as they disperse and
as they mix
with the gases in the stratosphere and
so
for understanding you know what we hope
and i think
um the people in the field is that we
can do these small scale
experimental studies that help you
populate models that will predict better
predict what happens if you did this at
a bigger scale
so the scale of this is tiny it's like
uh less than a minute of an emissions of
an aircraft
it's tiny but they hope to be able to
find out some important things about the
properties
of the chemical interactions and the way
the particles disperse
that would feed into models that would
help us make predictions
about what will happen when you do this
and also what materials
might be more optimal to use
and in this case so in this case they're
going to look at sulfates which we
talked about
but also materials that might have
better properties
and so two of those are calcium
carbonate which is what we're used to in
chalk
um and diamonds
so what they hope to do is
you know start down the path of finding
out more
about how you might optimize this in a
way to minimize the risks
and so uh any questions about that one
or shall i talk about
about the cloud yeah so
let's talk about clouds now um
[Music]
so the other uh the other effort is on
the other side of the united states
um this is an effort that's based at the
university of washington which is the
top
one of the top atmospheric science
institutions in the country
it's a partnership with pacific
northwest national labs department of
energy lab
and park which many of your community
may know it's the famous xerox park
who has since developed expertise in
aerosols
so the you know at the university of
washington they're looking to do
a set of experiments that would get at
this
um cloud brightening question and
their scientific research and their
experiments are classified as dual
purpose
so meaning that they are experiments
about understanding this climate
intervention technique can we brighten
clouds to actively cool climate
but they're also about getting at the
question of
what is this cloud aerosol effect what
is the accidental effect
of emissions having and how does this
work in the climate system more broadly
so what they're proposing to do is build
a specialized spray technology
so one of the characteristics of both
efforts
is that you need to create a almost a
nano mist of particles like
80 to 100 nanometers very consistently
at a massive scale and so it turns out
that that hasn't been done before
and so that's this sort of
you know how to generate this massive
number of tiny droplets
of materials of salt particles from
seawater
or you know calcium carbonate particles
uh some retired physicists and engineers
in silicon valley took on this problem
about eight years ago
and they've been working on it for four
days a week in their retirement
for free for the sake of their
grandchildren
to invent this nozzle that i'm showing
you which is the first step of being
able to generate the particles that you
need to study
here and so they're in the phase right
now
where because of covet they've had to
set up a giant tent
and do indoor spray tests and they hope
next year to go out and do what they
call individual plume experiments that's
the picture that you can see
of the little ship generating a plume
that's like one ship
traversing and then eventually they
would like to
undertake what they call a limited area
field experiment which would actually be
10 000 square kilometers
which is the size of a grid cell on a
climate model
and that would be the minimum scale at
which you could actually
potentially detect a brightening effect
yeah i guess i mean i maybe it makes
sense on reflection but
i guess i'm kind of surprised that um
this so much research is needed to
figure out how to make a nozzle to like
make droplets of aerosol
or of whatever
well yeah i think i was surprised too
um it turns out i think for certain
materials
and again because they're really talking
about like a nano mist
yes a lot of the applications for that
are are for like silicon chip
manufacturer
like asthma inhaler and so here we're
talking about three trillion particles a
second from one nozzle
and an apparatus that can generate 10 to
the 16th
particles and lift it up in you know a
few hundred years
and so um it's not nuclear fusion
and it wouldn't necessarily have taken
eight years if they were like properly
funded and it was a focus
program i mean these guys um
the lead armand newgermans funded this
with his own money
and he was trading biscotti he's from
belgium he was trading biscotti for
measurement instruments
you know over the course of the years
and so it's only recently in the past
year or two where where the program has
gotten
its first government funding from noaa
and some from the department of energy
varies relatively small
and more focused on the scientific
modeling
and some money from private philanthropy
which they're able to use for the
technology development
so but again going back to my comment
earlier
this has been a very taboo area for
scientists to even work in
and there has been you know there have
been no formal sources of funding for it
so that's made it go a lot slower and
the technology part is the hardest
and most controversial
all right but overall as as a point
you know these these things are very
nascent like
and and the problem we were talking
about in the beginning like predicting
what the system is going to do
that in order to evaluate and assess
these things properly
you need a better prediction system
because you're trying to say okay we're
going to pursue the system this way
in this way and predict that the outcome
will be better
than you know yeah so it's it's a tough
you know it's a tough challenge in terms
of getting enough research in
quickly all right
i hear you that makes sense um and
the one other thing i'll say yeah um
people have
you know people have sort of propagated
the idea that this is cheap and easy to
do
and that it could run away from us very
quickly
and that has not been my experience run
away in what sense
like everyone else some billionaire
could do
take a couple billion dollars and do it
or some little country could do it
the reality is oh as like even an attack
like not necessarily an attack but
an ungoverned attempt
to manage the climate system
uh you know from the perspective of one
you know one individual or one small
country or what have you
i see that's been a significant concern
amongst
you know social scientists and activists
and
um and and i guess what you know my
observation
working closely with it is like there
are at least two types of technology
that don't exist yet that we need
so we have a technology hurdle um these
things
scale linearly and they pretty much stop
when you stop
sorry are the are the two the two
technologies that we need the
the troposphere and the stratospheric
interventions
uh well specifically i was referring to
the aerosol generation technology
okay the thing i talked about just now
yeah and for the stratosphere we
probably actually need a new and
different kind of aircraft
okay okay and sorry can you define
aerosol
um yes so um
and i'll caveat this by saying i'm not a
scientist so my definition may not
be what a scientist would give you but
but generally speaking
um an aerosol is particles mixed with
gases and so
um so
it's uh like a manifestation in
air of a mixed blend of particles and
gases
yeah and you have some some small
mist of whatever
in the the atmosphere like it's hydrogen
and oxygen and whatever else and
co2 it's just like yeah that makes sense
and so um i'll i'll often talk about
particles because it's a little bit
clearer
um and what we're doing with these
technique techniques for the most part
is
you know dispersing particles yeah
in a way that they mix with the
atmosphere and um become an aerosol
yeah so
uh so i think that um we have
like like i would characterize the
challenge we have right now is that we
actually have a very low level of
information
and no technology and
these things would take you know a
number of years to develop
yeah well it's an interesting future to
imagine
the international politics of weather
of weather control like negotiating
um whether to stop the hurricanes or to
you know any of these more um
come in new new powers we might get over
the weather in the coming decades
well you bring it you bring up an
interesting point
um because as i've gotten into this
field i've learned about what's going on
and actually there's a an astonishing
amount of weather modification activity
going on
in the world um and in the united states
uh and so uh like an intentional
intentional yeah like i think i did hear
that that russia
did some sound like cloud seeding or
whatever it's called
to stop some event some important event
getting rained on or something like
yeah and that kind of thing like uh if
you remember the beijing olympics where
they
um seated clouds to generate rain to
clear the
uh pollution um so that kind of
localized
cloud seeding type stuff has gone on for
a long time
and of course i'm in colorado like
there's always been
um cloud seating for snow making
and so what's happened though in the
western united states
there's even an industry association for
weather modification
in the united states wow um that these
um like what started out as especially
snow making and a little bit of like
attempt to affect the snowpack
in the west has grown and so there are
actually major weather modification
efforts in like seven or eight western
states
in the united states and they're mostly
aimed at hydrology like snowpack
um and water levels well like is this is
the snowpack for like a like a ski
resort
well it started i i believe and i'm not
an expert on the history of this but
i believe that um snow making started
out from the ski resorts but when i say
snow pack it's really about the water
table
and so it's it's about affecting the the
the snow levels that generate the water
levels downstream
okay right so because in the west like
a lot of our water comes from snow okay
and so you want to seed more snow to get
more water
correct um and the government pays for
that
right and so um
[Music]
i i can't say for sure who pays okay
because again i i haven't looked at it
this is still
an exploration process but um
but there are fairly significant
initiatives in many western states
and like i said they're primarily aimed
at the problem of drought
and hydrology and so that's in the
united states and if you look at other
parts of the world like the united arab
emirates house they have a 400 million
dollar rainmaking fund
so can you know can we make rain in the
desert
and um all right you
you know flip side of the coin in
indonesia in january this was in the
news
they were seeding clouds offshore to
induce rainfall offshore to prevent
flooding
and they did that at a pretty big scale
in china again this year
or last year they announced a uh
a program to increase rainfall in the
tibetan plain
in an area the size of alaska
and so so we are starting to see
i think around the world and this
activity would likely grow
yeah where you have you know weather
extremes and attempts to deal with them
locally
yeah that makes sense and so are are
they doing this
with um yeah what are they using to do
this
um and again i'm not super expert but
a traditional material is silver dioxide
that's
what's proposed in the chinese program
and
many of like the weather the rain making
types of ideas
and so i think that um you know there
are two things we'll start to see i
think
as as climate extremes grow there's and
there's pressure
on politicians to act is
you know growing interest in you know
the potential for global mechanisms to
kind of reduce heat
and you know bottoms up efforts that
just continue to expand
that try to manage you know weather
extremes in these
kinds of ways all right
so um so we have this uh tropospheric
intervention
um by using aerosols to generate clouds
that will reflect sunlight
and then we have the uh the the
stratospheric intervention
um which
aims to release particles which do
something similar um
so how do you view the research
and and and and the project of
understanding these things as fitting in
with and informing efforts to
decrease uh greenhouse gas emissions
and then also the project of like
removing them from the atmosphere
if that's also something people are
looking into
yeah so i think i think they're all very
related because at the end of the day
from a silver lining perspective and a
personal perspective we see this as a
portfolio problem
so we have a complex system that we need
to manage back into a healthy state
and we have kind of a portfolio of
things that we need to apply at
different times in different ways to do
that
and in that way it's a bit like medicine
where you know the
the interventions i'm talking about or
sort of address
you know the immediate stressor yeah um
but
to restore the system to health you have
to address the underlying cause
where we see ourselves as maybe helping
bridge those things
is that um we are under invested
in climate research and climate
prediction
so in the united states our our entire
budget for climate research
is about two and a half billion dollars
and so if you put that in perspective
you know
that's like one tenth of an aircraft
carrier
it's half of a football stadium it's
you know it's paltry and this
is the most complicated
um computing intensive problem on planet
earth
so it takes massive super computing
capacity and all the analytical
techniques you can throw at it
to try to reduce the uncertainty around
what's going to happen to these systems
and and so
what i believe happened in the past few
decades
is the problem was defined as a need to
limit greenhouse gases
so if you think of an equation where one
side is the greenhouse gas is going in
and the other side is what happens to
the system on the other end
we've invested most of our energy in in
[Music]
climate climate advocacy and climate
policy about bringing
down greenhouse gases and we're under
invested
in really trying to understand predict
what happens on the other side
and so when you look at these climate
intervention techniques like i'm talking
about
it's pretty critical to understand and
be able to predict what
what happens on the other side and it
turns out if you're looking
at the whole portfolio particularly if
you want to blend in these sort of
nature-based solutions that could bring
down greenhouse gases
but they have complex interaction with
the system
right like building new forests or
putting nutrients on the ocean
that you know that need to
better understand the system and better
predict the system
turns out we really need that and
it would behoove us to be able to
understand and predict these tipping
points better
so i think that um where you know
then where the interventions come in is
to try to say well
what does reducing the heat stress get
you you know what does it get you in
terms of safety what time does it buy
you for these other things to take
effect and so that's kind of where
where we see ourselves fitting in we
care a lot
about mitigation about
you know let's let's move away from this
whole greenhouse gas
emissions business yeah we care a lot
about carbon removal
and accelerating efforts to do that and
if somebody comes up with a magical way
to do carbon removal
at scale in the next 10 years then we
won't need to do what we're doing
but that doesn't look like a high
probability thing
yeah and so what we've chosen to do is
to say there's a part of the portfolio
that is totally unserviced
there are no advocates there's almost no
research
it's taboo it's complicated it requires
innovation
that's where we're going to focus yeah
that makes sense
um so why don't you let's talk a little
bit about this
this taboo aspect um maybe some number
of listeners
are uh have some initial reaction like
any time human beings try to intervene
in complex systems there's always
unintended consequences or things happen
that we can't
predict or imagine um especially in
in in natural systems um
so how would you speak to or
or or um connect with someone who
who viewed this the project of releasing
aerosols into the atmosphere to create
clouds to reflect sunlight
if someone was skeptical of that project
and saw it as as dangerous how would you
uh yeah what would you say to such a
person
well so i'll start out by saying i have
a lot of sympathy with that yeah i
really do
and and um and if we were
you know 30 years ago
you know if you're at a different place
in this sort of risk equation
then this kind of thing really doesn't
make any sense at all and so
we're you know if we're in 1970 or 1980
and someone's saying look we just need
to economically
tune you know the incentives so that we
we phase greenhouse gases out of
you know the bulk of our economic system
that is infinitely smarter and less
risky
so and i and i believe that a lot of the
you know the principle and structure of
how we think about the climate problem
is based on that
because what we did was really stupid
and it would it would be the same thing
as if the doctor said well
you know you have stage one cancer stop
smoking
and you just kept on puffing away like
so
i i'm very sympathetic to this um
and but but you know again
coming from the concern the primary
concern that we're focused on
are now our forward outcomes and the
fact that we have this big safety
problem
and so we so now we're in a situation
where we have greenhouse gas
concentrations that we have
that are already there yeah and we have
warming
and system impacts that are already
there
and and some latency build in that mean
we're going to have more of those
and so that means we have to look at the
risk risk trade-off that
based on the situation that we're in now
where we have conducted the experiment
where we push all these aerosols into
the atmosphere that mostly trap heat
and change the system radically like we
did that
that was one form of you know human
intervention
that wasn't a very smart one
so what we have to look at now is we're
not saying that we know
that this is a good idea or that the
risks outweigh the benefits outweigh the
risks
but we're saying that we have very few
alternatives
today to
to act in ways that could help stabilize
the system
for a period of time and so that so
that's you know
for us it's about how quickly can we
generate
information to assess and do a
comparison
and and the better that we can project
what this farming is doing and the
better that we can
that we can optimize and predict what
these interventions might do
yeah that'll give us some options in a
place where we don't have them
yeah that makes sense um
and as a as a brief side note um if
you're accidentally
hitting your table that might be
something good to be mindful about
sorry no it's all good i got emphatic
yeah it's it's it's it's good for uh for
emphasis
um
only on issues you care about right um
so all right so let's
i'm so i'm interested in pursuing okay
well actually
um let's stay on this point of of
uh people who might be skeptical of this
um
so can you enumerate what the the the
main points are of detractors
so if someone is skeptical of this whole
approach and thinks like
look we just need to stick to removing
greenhouse gases like by natural
intervention by building forests and we
need to reduce
co2 emissions and greenhouse gas
emissions drastically
and to do anything else would be
you know just adding more danger to the
equation um
yeah so what what are the the main
points of someone who
who who comes with this problem with
with such a perspective
so i think the um you touched on two of
them already
um one is that the problem is actually
not moving that quickly
and so we should be focused on things
that
are you know more root cause even if
they take longer
um and then the second one being you
know the fact that this
introduces risks that are really hard to
quantify
um so but the
i would say the primary objection
um that's raised by people like al gore
most of the advocates around climate
that have a problem with this is what
they call the moral
hazard the idea that it
gets put forward as a panacea and
therefore
it slows down efforts to address the
underlying problem
and so this is sort of saying like
even research in this stuff could have a
societal negative effect
that it slows us down and doing what
we're really supposed to do
and so that um that has some interesting
kind of um angles on it one angle
which was talked about in a recent paper
by joseph aldi at
harvard um and also was talked about
with us by republicans we talked to
about this
early on was that
you know there's also the thesis that it
could have the opposite effect
that the sort of drastic nature of these
things
could actually signal to society and to
skeptics
the seriousness of the problem and so i
did a panel
with a bipartisan panel and the
republican
on the panel who's a moderate guy
climate pro climate guy
he said you know when we republicans
hear
these kinds of proposals coming from you
know people who are serious about
climate change it makes you more
credible
than when you come to us and say the sky
is falling but
none of these things are on the table
and so i thought that was interesting
early on i thought it was interesting
recently
that there's at least a an equal
possibility
that that these things as we look into
them
could wake everyone up in the same way
that
more drastic medical treatments do and
say look
this is very serious so on all fronts we
need to get very serious
but i think um in general
this idea of moral hazard you know it
comes up
pretty much at as soon as the idea is
there
and it can come up you know in the same
way that trump talks about planting
trees
um you know almost anything can be
positioned in a way
that you know could could be attempted
to use this as panacea
i actually think that one of the big
moral hazards of the climate
space has been the idea of winners and
losers because i think
many more powerful people assume that
this problem didn't apply to them
so i'm so you know i'm i
think they're not in a flooding zone
right or i can find my blog
like they can move they can move to
their bunker
yeah and that yeah and i think that the
people who put forward this idea of
winners and losers and climate did that
because they were very concerned
about the people who are impacted first
um
and for the most part they're the people
who didn't cause the problem you know
they're vulnerable people so there's
yeah
but but yeah the mistake was the mistake
was
in letting powerful people think that
this wasn't their problem
and so i think that was a big societal
moral hazard and in in this particular
case
i you know i'm optimistic that if we
talk about these things candidly
and we say look these are serious and
they have serious risks
and you we wouldn't use them if we had a
better choice
i i it's not clear to me that that moral
hazard
idea really holds but that is the
biggest reservation
and and and it's a reservation that yeah
that means that many people very
passionately object to research
that they don't want us to look into any
of this because it sets off this
societal problem
yeah um okay
that makes a lot of sense um
[Music]
i mean these are just kind of like very
side points but
um it's it's it i mean and it seems like
it more it seems like moral hazard
should be called something more like
information
hazard like the word moral seems
kind of a little bit confusing here
because it's like if people have the
information that like this kind of
intervention is possible then bad things
may happen like if they have this
information then bad things may happen
but like moral means like um
i don't know more like it has something
to do with ethics rather than the
consequences of information
um yeah so whatever no no no one here
has
control over how this language was
created well i i agree with you it's
you know it's an idea that comes from
economics originally about like
where the incentives are okay um
but but i think your point is well taken
because
you're exactly right is information is
dangerous
it's a masked way of saying that
information itself is dangerous
and that's a fundamental principle and i
find myself
in in meetings with advocates and
around this issue having to say look our
position
is that information helps with
fair and just consideration of this that
information is good not bad
but but i think you hit on an extremely
important point
that that it's a mass way of saying that
information is too dangerous for people
to handle
and our position is yeah information
about these things is what empowers
people
all over the world to think about them
for themselves
yeah the yeah i mean the like
there's a degree to which moral hazards
or information hazards
like lack uh like trust or confidence
and
and the recipients of that information
um
which may be which may or may not be
valid
um depending on the issue and the
information um
here you argue that this information is
necessary to be known and shared
and then people can make informed
decisions
that's that's our argument and i think
that
um there is a i'll call it a marketing
hazard
that you know people take certain kinds
of information and package it
and market it in ways that are not
useful
yeah and but that that exists in all
kinds of arenas and so
for us we want to keep going forward and
saying look
let's generate information about this so
we can all consider it
together um and
and that but that's a you know
i guess one thing i should say about
that because i was so shocked by it when
i started working in climate that this
idea of moral hazard
it isn't new to this issue it was
actually it actually came up when they
started looking at adaptation research
in the in the ipcc and the climate
community and
research and adaptation was considered
to create a moral hazard
and so it didn't move forward and one of
the reasons that
we as a society have relatively low
level of information
about the things i was talking about
like infrastructure impacts
and the things you need to know for
adaptation is because there was a very
strong objection to it
based on moral hazard and the same was
true of carbon removal
you know which has only recently come
into consideration in the ipcc
so you know this information is
dangerous idea because
it will affect you know our motivation
around this one part of the portfolio
that we think is the most important
i would i would argue that that's
already slowed us down
in really critical ways and so you know
this is just another of those
where we need to say okay we need to
rethink this whole concept of moral
hazard because it hasn't helped us
yeah sorry so what is the what is the
marketing hazard
of discussing the infrastructure risk of
climate change
so this isn't the marketing hazard this
is the um
you know so going back say 20 years ago
in the ipcc and the climate community
that there's this question of how much
should we invest
in looking at adaptation how communities
will adapt oh
i oh i see how can we end up that's
right
and there was a strong objection to
adaptation
research because it was felt
that it would disincentivize
uh greenhouse gas reduction
and i think that's been a a pretty
tragic mistake
because in my view and probably people
like you and me well if you had started
research adaptation 20 years ago you'd
have much more information about what a
[ __ ] show this is going to be
and more incentive to to reduce
greenhouse gases
not less because this is not very
adaptable
but that was the but but the effect of
that was
a real dampening of any investment in
adaptation research
and so like even adaptation research in
the u.s federal system is relatively new
because it was it was so constantly
suppressed
yeah i mean the fear there is that like
mick
alpha corp will come and be like you
know it's okay that we're
all have all these these th all these
emissions because
we can just do this really cheap we'll
just make clouds later
right and so they can do like i mean i
feel like corporations have done
extremely
effective disinformation campaigns on
scientific issues like
like smoking um and
and other things and so i mean i i
assume that would have been
what some of the fear would have been
with regards to
adaptation techniques and here were
were putting stratospheric and
tropospheric intervention as
uh adaptation techniques right
well in in what i was talking about
before i wasn't referring to this
category but the more traditional
adaptation techniques like
building you know dams like trees and
walls and
planning new different types of
vegetation and things like that
traditional adaptation right was
considered a moral hazard
and so i i was trying to say like i
recognize that what i'm talking about in
these climate interventions is
fairly unusual but
even traditional adaptation techniques
to protect people
were suppressed now in terms of what
you're saying
i i appreciate your point and there it's
been raised to me before that oh maybe
oil
companies will jump on this as a panacea
for what they're doing
and so it's so we talked to oil
companies about it
talked to a couple of them and their
their response was we wouldn't go
anywhere near this because we're not
considering them
because it would be admission that ties
their you know fossil fuels to warming
so so they're they're much more likely
to invest in carbon removal techniques
and and things that are more closely
associated with the actual emissions
than they are
anything like this so
i i think that for some of those things
um sorry because they're not
conceding that they created the warming
and they're certainly
but if they're creating the carbon but
if they're creating the carbon and now
they're like okay we're going to help
take
out the carbon isn't that admitting that
they contributed to the problem
yes but they're not conceding that they
you know that they are the under
that they are the absolute and
proven cause of all of this form
oh so they like inject the like
uncertainty that
that people will say like there's
weather and like this is all just
weather
and like the earth naturally fluctuates
and like we'll help take
co2 out of the atmosphere but you know
maybe it wasn't really us
well and if you think about them as you
know they're legal fiduciary entities
and so creating a a direct
tie between themselves and warming is
different than
not doing that so i think that
yes sir i don't see why taking co2 out
of the atmosphere
versus like saying that you can make
clouds to reflect sunlight like admits
to any difference in degree
of of culpability for the problem
well so you know it might be worth
asking around this is how it was
described to me
by one major oil company that
you know there there's a fairly
substantial difference between
you know them looking at greenhouse
gases which are kind of
part of the you know landscape of
what they do and then you know
the actual warming and cooling of the
planet
and so which they're not they're not
admitting to be directly responsible for
all right
yeah um um
yeah okay and so the other just fine i
guess i guess the punctuation i will say
is for those listeners who are concerned
about oil companies doing this
really not happening um and so if you're
concerned about some
you know there being someone doing it
this is definitely we can't count on
them to bill us out and
cool the planet this way because they're
really really not yeah
yeah yeah and my last like
quip i was i was suffering over while
you were speaking
at some point was um you know if if
listeners or anyone else
are sick and tired of the amount of
disinformation that
that already exists like get ready for
the
the the level 5.0 conspiracy theories
that are going to happen
like like chemtrail 5.0 when we have to
start potentially
you know using these these these mist
generators to
to to create clouds um
there could be even like significant
social disruption just
by governments undertaking like that
kind of project
it would seem well that's where i think
um
generating information and talking about
this in a way that's well grounded
is helpful um that's why um
you don't hear me use the term
geoengineering it's not a particularly
accurate term and it sort of
amplifies triggers um whereas climate
intervention is a more accurate term
and it helps kind of ground the
conversation in what we're talking about
um the same thing when we explain that
these are based on processes that are
observed in nature and some of them are
already happening
so this isn't some big new sci-fi you
know we're going to throw
you know bombs at hurricanes or
something
just getting the conversation better
grounded i've had chemtrails people at
my talks
i did a talk at the interval cafe the
line
and i had a guy set up a tripod in the
back and record it and he was giving out
these little buttons that had an
airplane with a little trail coming out
and you know strike through it
yeah it was fantastic um and i had a
really long conversation with them and
it's
when you you know when you ha when you
talk about it in
this way it's kind of hard hard to argue
with
um the reality is that you know there is
no secret
government program to do these things
and there are definitely
no mind-altering chemicals involved in
any proposals
well that's what you would be saying if
there were mind-altering chemicals
in there right in the fair point
that's a fair point um so we tend i mean
we tend to try to orient the dialogue
at the sort of you know 90 percent uh
across
the political and thought spectrum bar
five percents um
you know churning yeah yeah yeah
it's not it's not a super serious
consideration but um
yeah something to be maddened about in
the future
um well one of the
one of the other things i'll say with
respect to like the other side of the
spectrum
kind of the climate denial climate um
side of the spectrum is because we work
in the policy sphere in the united
states and so we have conversations
across the political spectrum
that in a in a strange way you know
coming out the problem
from this angle where we talk about heat
stress and we talk about
these interventions helps kind of
create a new insertion point for people
who are
you know who are
shut down in the traditional kind of
dialogue around climate change
and so we've had some pretty good
success actually
you know talking with people on the
right side of the spectrum are people
who are approaching
the climate problem from a way that's
not super well grounded in the science
to kind of start by talking about heat
stress and what's happening and the
symptoms that we're seeing
and these kinds of approaches to it and
then
walking them backwards into you know
will you absolutely positively have to
take down greenhouse gases
so it has you know interestingly and
kind of unexpectedly
created maybe another another sort of
pathway
for dealing with at least parts of those
populations and
policy people
all right so i'd be interested in
pivoting here into
like the international implications of
this and then also talking about this
risk in the context of other
global catastrophic and existential
risks so
um the question here now is uh
what are the risks of international
conflict around setting the
global temperature via co2 reduction and
geo sorry
geoengineering is the is the word the
bad word
um and climate intervention um
so like i don't know there are some
countries which
may benefit from the earth being
slightly warmer hotter you talked about
how there were no winners or losers
um but there seemed to there are winners
like if it if it only changes a little
bit like if it gets a little bit warmer
then like parts of russia may be happier
than
they were otherwise um they may be more
accessible
and and available for agriculture and so
like the international community as we
gain more and more efficacy over
the the problem of uh climate change and
and our ability to um mitigate it to
you know whatever degree will be
impacting like
the weather and agriculture and
livability of regions for countries all
across the the planet
so how do you view this this this
international negotiation problem of
of of mitigating climate change and
setting setting the global temperature
to something appropriate
so i don't tend to use the framing of
setting the global temperature
okay um it's not clear to
us that um i mean we're really really
far
from having like a fine grain management
capability for this so
we tend to think of it more in the
context of
you know preventing certain kind of
disastrous events in the climate system
and so i think in that framing where you
say well we can develop this technology
where we have knobs and dials
for creating favorable conditions in
some places and not others
that would be potentially a problem but
it
doesn't necessarily look like that's how
it works
um so it's possible that some places
like parts of russia
um parts of canada might for a period of
time
have more favorable climate conditions
but it's not a static
circumstance and so the problem that you
have is well the arctic opens up
siberia gets warmer and for a couple of
decades that's nicer
but that's in the context of these
um abrupt change risks that we were
talking about
where that situation is just a
transitory state
to some worse states
and so the question you're asking me is
okay well
maybe behold uh you know we hold the
system
to where you know russia's happier
in in this sort of different state that
they have but
um you know i think that
the massive challenge which we don't
know if we can do
is just whether we can keep the system
stable enough
to prevent lots of these and so the idea
that you can
you know stabilize the system in a way
that's
different than now um
but still prevents these like cascading
outcomes
that's a pretty like i would say not the
highest probability scenario
um yeah so go ahead and so i think that
but i think there there's certainly
validity in your question
which is this just makes everybody super
nervous
and it is the case that this is not a
collective action
capability one of its features is that
it does not require everyone in the
world to agree
and so our and that is very
unstable concerning state for a lot of
people
and it is it is true that it
its outcomes cannot be fully predicted
and so there's a high degree of
likelihood that everyone would be better
off
or that the vast majority of of the
world would be better off
but there will be outcomes on places
that might be different
and so it's more likely rather than
people electively tuning the gods and
making things more favorable for
themselves
just that you know three to five percent
of the world thinks they're worse off
and while we've tried to keep the thing
more or less stable
but i think behind your question is you
know
even the dialogue around this is pretty
unnerving and has the potential to
promote instability and conflict
and one of the things that we we've seen
in the past that's been super helpful
is for scientific cooperation
lots of global cooperation in the
evolution of the research and the
science so that everybody's got
information
and then we're all dealing from an
information base
or you know where people can be part of
the discussion
because our strong hypothesis is like
we're kind of
at looking at the edge of the cliff or
you know
down into the [ __ ] show where we might
not have so much disagreement
that we need to do something but we all
need information about
about this stuff right
so we have so we have done some work
in silver lining at looking at this um
and how the international community has
handled things better or worse
when it comes to environmental threats
like this
so our favorite model is the montreal
protocol which is the
both the scientific research and the
structure
that help manage what is many perceived
to be an
existential risk around the ozone layer
and so that was you know that that was a
smaller more focused case of
you know you have a part of the system
that if it falls outside a certain
parameter
lots and lots of people are going to die
and we have some really rigorous science
we have to do to figure out
where we can let that go and not let it
go
and the world has managed that very well
over the past couple of decades and we
managed to walk
back from the cliff restore the ozone
layer
and we're still managing it now and so
we kind of see some similarities in this
problem space
of saying you know we've got to be
really really focused about what
what we can can't let the system do
and then get really strong science
around what our options
are
yeah so the the other thing i'll say
about montreal protocol in case people
aren't aware
is it is the only environmental forum
environmental treaty
that is signed by all countries in the
world
and it is the i believe maybe the only
environmental forum that has
numbers membership of all countries in
the world
and so uh there are lots of aspects of
that that are
really good model to follow for
something like this i think
okay so
[Music]
like there's the problem of runaway
climate change
where um
[Music]
tipping like the destruction of
like important ecosystems lead to
tipping points
and that leads to tipping cascades and
without the reduction of co2 we get
worse and worse climate change where
like
everyone is worse off in that context
there is increased global
[Music]
destability um so there's going to be
more conflict with like the migrations
of people and the
increase of disease um it's just going
to be a stressor on all of
human civilization but you know if that
doesn't happen
then there is this kind of
later 21st century potential concern
of um more sophisticated
you know weather manipulation and like
weather engineering technologies
um making the
the question of kind of you know
constructing and setting the weather in
certain ways as a more valid
uh international like geopolitical
problem but that that obviously being
like secondary and less important um
but you know primarily the concern is
is just you know obviously regular
climate change with
the the stressors and conflict that are
induced by that
um and then um
[Music]
an important model for this is the what
you call the
so the montreal protocol which um
was effective in solving the the
the the ozone layer problem from was it
plural
fluorocarbons i don't even know what the
word is is that right
hfcs hydrofluorocarbons yeah there are
other chemicals too
so those are the mostly the refrigerant
chemicals
okay i see all right
um but but one thing i'll say uh
to your point um just to clarify a
little bit about weather modification
and the sort of um expansion of that
activity
so i think that that's already happening
and likely to happen throughout the
century
um and let's say that that climate
were to move along a more smooth curved
path
we would see more of that in in the
escalation of that
and and the expansion of that is a
problem
not not necessarily people using it
as a sort of a a weaponized idea
but as as weather modification
activities get larger they have what are
called telegraphic
effects they affect other places
so i might be trying to cool the great
barrier reef but i might affect
you know whether in bali and if i'm
china and i'm doing
you know trying to do weather
modification the areas the size of
alaska is pretty sure that i'm going to
be affecting other places
and if it's big enough yeah that's right
that's global circulation
so i do think that um that
actual that aspect like that's coming
onto the radar now
and that is an international
decision-making problem
as you correctly say because that's
actually
in some ways a bit even almost a bit of
a harder problem than the global one
because we've got these sort of national
efforts where i might be
engaged in my own um jurisdiction
but i might be affecting people outside
yeah and i should also say so
everybody's clear
that um weather modification for the
purpose of
weapons is banned by international
treaty
um a treaty called nmod and it's
actually
it arose out of u.s weather modification
efforts
in the vietnam war where we were trying
to use weather as a weapon and
subsequently agreed not to do that
right yeah this is interesting i mean
i mean i've never really thought much
about that but um that's interesting
right
um so
um let's see here um
so we're wrapping up here on the like
geopolitics
and the political conflict around
climate change
um like can you describe to what extent
there is gridlock
around the issue i mean like different
countries have
different degrees of incentives they
have different policies and plans and
philosophies
uh you know one might be more interested
in focusing on industrializing
like to meet its own needs and so it
would deprioritize
um uh uh reducing co2 emissions
um it could be a poor country or could
be a country that just wants to
industrialize further
um so how do you view like the game
theory and the incentives
and um getting international
coordination on
on on climate change when yeah we'd all
be better off if this didn't happen
but like um not everyone is is ready or
willing to pay
the same price
yeah so i'll speak to that in a couple
of different sides
because i'm not an expert in all sides
of this but um
you know from what i understand that a
relatively modest price for carving so
i mean the main issue that we have now
is that we have this
externality this externalized costs that
that
people aren't paying for the debt you
know the damage that they're doing
and so a modest you know charge for that
for greenhouse gas emissions
my understanding is that that a
you know relatively modest price for
carbon can set
the incentives such that innovation
moves faster
and you reach the thresholds of economic
viability for some
of these um non-carbon
approaches faster and
that that you know i come from silicon
valley so i think innovation is a big
part of the equation
you mean like you mean like solar and
wind well there's solar and wind which
are the traditional techniques and then
there are emerging things which could be
hydrogen fuel cells it could be fusion
energy it could be
um and there are really important things
in the category of waste management
agriculture you know it's not just
energy and cars right
these other areas that are big
greenhouse gas emitters
and they're and we're just not reaching
the economic threshold
where we're driving innovation fast
enough and we're
um and we're reaching profitability fast
enough for these systems to be viable
so with a little turn of the dial right
in terms of
pricing that in you get all of that to
go faster
and i'm a believer in moving that
innovation faster
means that the price of these low carbon
techniques will come down
and you'll also accelerate offlining the
fossil fuel
generate or the greenhouse gas
generating stuff
so i think that you know it's not
sensible
that we're not you know building in like
a robust
mechanism for having that price
incentive
and that that price incentive will
behave differently
in the developed countries versus
the emerging markets and the developing
countries
and it might need to be managed
differently in terms of the costs that
they face
but it's really important in the
developing countries that we develop
policies that incentivize them
not to build out greenhouse gas
generating infrastructure
however we do that because a lot of them
are at inflection points right where
they can start building power plants and
building out infrastructure
and so we also we also need to look
closely at aligning policies and
incentives for them that they just go
ahead and build green
and it might be a little bit more
expensive which means that we have to
help with that
but that would be a really smart thing
for us to do what we can't do
is expect developing countries who
mostly didn't cause the problem
to also eat the impact in terms of not
having electricity
and some of the benefits that we have of
things like
you know running water and basic needs
yeah
so i think i i don't i don't actually
think this is rocket science
i'm not you know i'm not a total expert
but i think what
the mechanisms that that are needed are
not super comp
complicated the getting the the
political support for them is what the
problem is
and so so a a a core solution here being
increased funding into innovation and to
like the the efficacy and efficiency of
renewable energy resources which don't
pollute the r d funding is key
right yeah and i think in the us we've
actually been pretty good at that in
a lot of parts of that spectrum but you
also have to have the mechanisms on the
market side
because where right now you have
effectively fossil fuels being
subsidized in terms of not being charged
for the problem they're creating
and sometimes we're subsidizing them
beyond that which is just bonkers
so um so we've got us so basically we've
got to
we've got to embed the costs in the
fossil fuel side
of the damage that they're doing and
that makes the market um mechanisms work
better for these emerging things
and the emerging things are going to
start out being more expensive
until they scale okay and so we have
this problem right now where we have
some emerging things they're expensive
how do we get them to market fossil
fuels are still cheaper
and so you know that's the problem where
it will eventually sort itself out but
we need to sort itself out
quickly so we've got to try to get in
there and
fix that push it from behind
right all right so i'm i'm mindful of
the time here now just a few few more
questions if we might have some some
time for them to wrap up on
sure um so
let's talk about climate change in the
context of of global and catastrophic
sorry let's let's talk about climate
change in the context of existential
risks and global catastrophic risks
um the way that i use the these language
is
is to say that global catastrophic risks
are ones which would kill some large
fraction of
of human civilization but wouldn't lead
to extinction
and existential risks lead to like all
humans dying or
all earth originating intelligent life
dying
um and the the relevant distinction here
for me
is that um the existential risks like
cancel the entire future so there could
be
you know billions upon billions or
trillions of
of experiential life years in the future
um
if we don't go extinct um
and so like that is kind of
this this value that is being added into
the equation of trying to understand
which
which risks are the ones to to pay
attention to um
so i mean you can react to this framing
if you'd like i'd be interested what you
think about it
and also just how you see the the
relative importance of climate change
uh in in the context of global and
catastrophic risks
sorry global and global catastrophic and
existential risks
and um uh how you see its
interdependence with other issues
so i'm i'm mainly talking about climate
change as
being in a context of something like um
you know other pandemics
other than covet 19 which may kill large
fractions of the population
and synthetic bio risk which in
a sufficiently dangerous engineered
pandemic
could possibly be existential um or
an accidental nuclear war or
misaligned artificial super intelligence
that could
uh lead to the human species extinction
so
um yeah how do you think about climate
change in the context of
of all these very large risks well i
appreciate the question
um i think one of the characteristics
that climate change has oh
many of the risks that you describe how
the characteristic of that they are hard
to quantify
um and they're hard to predict um and
some of them are sort of like big black
swan events like
um you know like even more deadly
pandemics
or you know pandemic stories and
artificially engineered things
so um so climate climate change i think
shares that characteristic that it's
hard to predict
i think that climate change um
when you dig into it you can see that
there are analytical deficiencies
that make it um very likely that we're
underestimating the risk
and so that's like
so that's something i'd say you know in
the spectrum between sort of
catastrophic and existential
we have not done the work to dig into
the areas in which
we are not currently adequately
representing the risk
and so um so i would say that
um there's a definite possibility that
is
that it's existential and that that
possibility is currently
um under analyzed and possibly
underestimated
can you can you can you expand that then
like how could it possibly be be
existential well so i think there are
two
two ways that it's existential in the
sense that
you know and i'm not an expert on like
outlier conditions for this
i watch a lot of sci-fi i like
post-apocalyptic sci-fi and the
different scenarios they have for they
live in cheyenne mountain or they live
in bubble
or they live on a you know um a space
orbit or whatever
um i've watched all seasons of the 100
but um but i think that
you know so so i'll say i'm not an
expert in like
survivability and outlier conditions but
there were two
you know if we just look at two
phenomenon that are part of like
non-zero probability projections for
climate one is this
like this example that i showed you
where warming goes beyond like five or
six degrees c
okay and the jury's the jury's pretty
far out on what that means for
humans remember i i talked to you about
like the wet bulb phenomenon
of the human body being able to survive
yeah and what we can engineer for that
and what it means about the
all the conditions of the land and the
sea and everything else yeah
so the question is like how high does
temperature go
yeah and then what does that mean in
terms of
you know the population livability curve
um this and and that part of what's
involved in that how high does
temperature go
is the biological species and their
relationship
to the physics and chemistry of the
planet
and so this this concern that i had from
pete warden at nasa ames that i had
never heard before
talking to him was that
and he spent time looking at sort of
planetary conditions in other places too
is that at some point in the collapse of
biological life
particularly in the ocean you have a
change in the chemical interactions
that produce the atmosphere that we're
familiar with
so for example there the biological life
at the surface of the ocean the
phytoplankton and other organisms they
generate a lot of the oxygen that we
breathe
in the air same with the forests
and so the question is whether you get
collapse
in the biological systems that generate
breathable air
now if you watch sci-fi you could say
well we can engineer that
no and that starts to look more like
engineering ourselves to live on mars
which i'll you know i'm happy to talk
about why i don't think that's a
solution
yeah but but so i think that
you know it's certainly reasonable for
people to say well
could that really happen there is some
non-zero probability that that could
happen that we don't understand very
well
and we've been reluctant to explore and
so i think that
you know my challenge back to people
about this being an existential risk
is that the possibility that's an
existential risk
yeah in a near term you think
maybe higher than we think
and the gaps in our analysis of that are
are
concerning yeah i mean the question is
like
do you know every like do you know
everything you need to know about all of
the complex systems on planet earth that
help to like
maintain the like small bandwidth of
conditions
for which human beings can exist and the
answer is like no i don't
um and then the question is like well
like how likely it is is it that like
climate change will perturb those
systems in such a way that
it would lead to an existential
catastrophe well it's like non-zero but
besides that i don't
really have a yeah i don't i don't know
well in one thing to look at that i
think everyone should look at who's
interested in this is the observations
of what's happening in the system now
okay and how they compare their
projections and so
what's happening in the system now are
you know collapses of some biological
life
changes and some of the systems that are
indicative that this risk might be
higher than we think
has the plan go ahead and so if you look
at things like
i think there was uh you know research
coming out that estimates that we may
have already lost like 40
of the phytoplankton on the surface of
the ocean
um so much so that the documentary
filmmaker
who made chase and coral was thinking
about making a documentary about this
about phytoplankton yeah and
phytoplankton i
i i think of it as the api layer between
the ocean and the atmosphere
it's a translation layer it's really
important and so
you know those are the kinds of things
and then i go to my friends who are
climate modelers
and they're like yeah phytoplankton
isn't well represented in
the climate models there are over 500
species of phytoplankton and we have
three of them in the climate models
and so you look at that and you say okay
well there's a risk that we don't
understand very well
um so so you know from my perspective
we have this non a non-zero risk in this
category
i'd be happy if i was overstating it and
if it was really really low
but it appears to me that it's it may
not be
yeah okay so that's all new information
and interesting
um the so in
in the context of the existential risk
community that i'm most familiar with
um like climate change is
like the way in which it's said to
potentially
lead to existential risks is by like
destabilizing global human systems that
would lead to
the actualization of like other
things that are existential risks so
like um
if you care about nuclear war or
synthetic bio or
pandemics or
getting ai right um that's all
a lot harder to do and control in in the
context of a much
hotter earth and so the other question i
had for you speaking of
hotter earths um has the earth ever been
5
c hotter than it is now like while there
was
while mammals have been on it so
i'm not an expert on paleoclimate
conditions um especially the question of
mammals
um hasn't that hot well humans have been
on it
i see um but i'm not i'm not expert
enough to know
as far as the mammal picture i'm gonna
guess
probably yes the issue that
so so i want to touch on the first
points that you were making
too but about the um societal cascade
that might
be um but but on this question
the the issue that we have and i'm
actually gonna
i'm actually gonna show one more let's
do it
um just to be super super clear
about you know the problem the
the problem with um
with the warming isn't just whether or
not the earth has ever been this form
but it's the pace of warming yeah and so
if you look at over the past you know
just the past couple thousand years
how far how far and how fast we're
pushing the system
um that normally when the earth goes
through its fluctuations of temperature
and you can see in the past 2000 years
like it's been small fluctuations but
over the you know hundreds of thousands
of millions of years it's been bigger
but it's happened over very long periods
of time like hundreds of thousands of
years
which means that all the little
organisms and all the big structures are
adapting in this very slow
way and in in this
situation where we're pushing it this
fast there's just
the natural adaptation you know is very
very low
you know you have species of fish and
stuff that can move to different places
but
it's really not it's happening so fast
in in earth
in earth system terms that there's no
adaptation happening
that's right that makes sense
mean yeah i mean i was just asking
because if
if if mammals had gotten through a long
period of
it being you know three to five c hotter
then maybe that'd be
good news for us um i was
sorry i'm having a little technical
challenge here trying to get back to you
um i can't seem to escape
out of my are you you're trapped in your
presentation
i'm trapped in my presentation i don't
know which news there we go
um so but to your other point
about you know climate change setting
off um
existential threats to society in other
ways i think that's
very true and that climate change
um is likely to heighten the risk
of like nuclear conflict
um and a couple different vectors and
it's also likely to heighten the risk
that we you know throw biological
solutions out there
his results we can't predict yeah and
and and the meltdown of nuclear reactors
for sure yeah so um
so i think you know one of the facets of
climate change that might be a little
bit different than like runaway ai
is just that it applies stress across
every human
and every natural system and so
that could pop you know where you guys
kind of look at existential pop threats
like things that could pop into
a sudden catastrophe you know it it you
know
it's got a number of ways in which you
know it
it could drive pop threats like that
yeah yeah i see
yeah we're we're on spaceship earth and
um
sometimes there's there's things that we
can't see but right now we're like
driving towards a meteor field
and we're we're arguing about when to
turn the steering wheel and how hard
because uh flying in this direction is
is convenient for now something like
that
that's right we we overestimate our
force field
yeah we'll have to we'll we'll we'll
reroute
power from force field to that's right
to change directions
um
yeah so yeah so so
this last point here then on uh
climate change contextualized in this
field of understanding around global
catastrophic and existential risks
um uh fli
views it as itself as being a part of
the effective altruism community
um and many of the listeners are
effective altruists
and eighty thousand hours has come up
with this um
this is this simple framework for
thinking about um
you know what kinds of projects and
endeavors you should take on
um and so the framework is just thinking
about tractability scope and
neglectedness
um so tractability is just like how much
you can do to actually affect the thing
scope is how big of a problem is it how
many people does it affect
and neglectedness is like how many
people are working on it um so you want
to work on things that are
highly tractable or tractable
that have a large scope and that are
neglected
um so like i think the the
there's a view or the sense of climate
change is that
um i mean from our conversation it seems
very tractable
um if we can get human civilization and
coordinate on this it's
something that we can you know do a lot
about um i guess it's another question
on how tractable it is to actually get
countries and and and corporations to to
coordinate
on this um but the scope is you know
global
um and would in the very least affect
our generation in the next few
generations um
possibly and it's but it's uh it's it
seems to not be neglected
um relative to other risks um
you might disagree with about that like
maybe it's it's it's it
one could say that it's neglected
relative to how much attention it
deserves
um but so i'm i'm i'm curious to
to to know how you would react to this
tractability scope and neglect in this
framework
um being applied to to climate change
and um all
and in the context of other global
catastrophic and existential risks
well so um firstly i'm i'm a big fan of
the framework
i was familiar with it before and um
it's not dissimilar
to the approach that we took and
founding silver lining
and so where i think uh this issue
might fit into that framework um depends
on whether
you put climate change all in one bucket
and treat it
as um not neglected or you say in the
portfolio of responses to climate change
of which um you know we have
a significant gap in terms of ability to
mitigate heat stress while we work on
other parts portfolio
that part is entirely neglected and so
um so i think for for us
it's about you know having to dissect
the climate change problem and
we have this collective action problem
which is a hard problem to solve to
ultimately
move industrial and other systems away
from greenhouse gas emissions and we
have the system
instability problem which requires
that we somehow alleviate the heat
stress before the system
breaks down too far and so
i would say in that context um
you know if your community looks at
climate change as a relatively slowly
unfolding problem which has a lot of
attention
then it wouldn't fit if you look at
climate change as having
some meaningful risk of you know
catastrophic
existential um
unfolding you know in the next 30 to 50
years
and not having response measures
to try to stabilize the system then it
fits
really nicely because it's not
um it's so under service that i
represent
the only ngo in the world that advocates
for research in this area
and um and so you know so it depends on
how your community thinks about it but
we look at those as quite different
problems
in a way so the problem of
for example uh adaptation research um
which has historically been stigmatized
but
we can apply this this framework to this
and see that
um you know you know if you that you
might get like a high return on impact
if you focus on supporting and doing
research
in adaptation technologies which would
be the tropospheric or stratospheric
interventions
um like the corrupt right so most people
don't include these techniques
under the banner of adaptation just so
just yeah
okay sure what does this count as then
um
climate intervention climate
intervention okay so
climate intervention technologies then
being uh
neglected that's right and so i think
that
um what's interesting to me
and and the people that i work with on
this problem is that these climate
intervention
technologies have the potential to have
very high leverage on the problem
in the short term yeah and so from a
from a philanthropic perspective or an
activist perspective
oftentimes i'm you know i'm engaged with
people are looking for leverage
like where can i really make a
difference in terms of supporting
research or policy
and you know i'm in this because
i literally i came from tech into
climate looking what is the most
under serviced highest leverage part of
the space
and i landed here um and so i think that
you know if your criteria that it's
under service and potentially high
leverage
then then this fits pretty well
um it's not the same as you know
addressing the longer term problem of
greenhouse gases
yep but it has very high leverage on the
stability risk
you know in the next 50 years or so yeah
that's right that makes sense
um so if if that's compelling to some
number of listeners
um uh how would you suggest that someone
um what is your recommendation for
for action or participation for such
persons if you think that like okay this
uh
climate intervention stuff is is is
compelling and and if
if i'm taking a portfolio approach to my
impact or altruism
and i want to put some of it into into
this uh
how do you recommend they do that well
so it's interesting timing because we're
just a few weeks of
uh launching something called this uh
safe climate research initiative
where we're funding a portfolio of
research programs and
to try to help catalyze it forward so
what we do at silver lining is try to
help drive
philanthropic funding for these you know
high leverage nascent research efforts
that are going on
and then try to help drive government
funding and effective policy
so that we can get resources moving in
the
in the big climate research system so
so for people looking for that um when
we when we launched the safe cloud or
when we
when we started talking about the safe
climate research initiative
we were agnostic as to whether you know
if you want to give money to silver
lining
for the fund or you want to donate to
these programs directly
so we interface with most of the
you know maturish programs in the united
states and quite a few around the world
mature and emerging and we can direct
people
based on their interests whether alumni
where the you know
parts of the world there are
opportunities for funding really high
caliber things
latin america the uk india
um and so so we're happy to say
you know you can donate to our fund and
we're just
moving through like getting seed funding
to these programs
um as we can or we can help connect you
with programs based on your interests in
different parts of the world that you're
in
technology versus science versus impacts
so so that's one way um
for some philanthropists who are aware
of the
leverage on government r d and
government policy
silver lining's been very effective in
starting to kind of turn the dial
on government funding and we have some
pretty big aspirations
not only to get funding directly in
assessing these interventions but also
in
expanding our capacity to do climate
prediction quickly
so so that's another way where you know
you can fund advocacy and we would
appreciate it
um so happy to be accepting donations
we're definitely accepting donations
we're definitely happy to connect people
or be a conduit for funding
research directly all right
just looking here um so
all right so let let's let's let's end
on a on a fun one here then
um you mentioned that uh you
so we were talking a little before we
started about your your visit planet
earth
uh picture behind you um
and that you you use that as uh
as a message uh against uh the
colonization of of mars
so why don't you think uh mars is a
solution to
all of the human problems on earth
well let's just start by saying you know
i grew up on star trek
and so i the colonization of mars and
the rest of the
universe is appealing to me but um
the as far as the solutions to climate
change
or you know an escape from it um just to
level set because i've had serious
conversations with people and i lived
for 12 years in silicon valley
spent a lot of time with the long now
community and you know people have a
passion for
for these you know for this vision of
living on another planet and the idea
that we might be able to
you know move off of this one if it
becomes dire
yeah the reality is and and it goes back
to education i got from very serious
scientists the problem with
living on other planets um it's not an
engineering problem or physics
problem it's a biology problem
but our bodies are fine tuned to the
conditions of earth
um radiation gravity the air
the colors and so we degrade pretty
quickly when we go off planet
and that's a harder problem to solve
than building a spaceship or a bubble
and so that's not a problem that gets
solved right away
and we can see it from the conditions of
astronauts that come back after a few
years
in orbit you know it's just not not
great
and so that the kinds of problems that
we would need to solve
to actually have like quality of life
living conditions on mars or anywhere
else
are going to take a while um longer than
what we think are the 30 to 50-year
instability problem that we have here on
earth
and we are so
you know finely tuned to the conditions
of earth like the goldilocks
sort of zone that we're in that it's a
really
really hard thing to replicate anywhere
else and so it's really not very
rational to it's a much it's actually
much easier problem to solve
to try to repair earth than it is to try
to create
the conditions of earth somewhere else
yeah so i mean these things might not be
mutually exclusive
right so i mean i mean it really seems
to be a problem of like resource
allocation like it's not one or the
other
it's like how much are we going to put
into each
and so on it's less of a problem of
research
allocation i think than of time horizon
well so i meant
so sorry i meant resource allocation
sorry resource allocation than time
horizon
so so i think that um
the kinds of scientific and technical
problems that you have to solve
to meaningfully have people live on mars
oh yeah that's a harder problem that's
beyond a 50-year time horizon
yeah and um and our concern is that the
climate instability problem
is inside a 50-year time horizon
so yeah that's right so that's the main
issue
is that over the long haul you know
there are advanced technologies and
probably bioengineering things we need
to do
and maybe um you know
engineering of planets that we need to
do for that to work
yeah and so over the next 100 or 200
years that would be really cool
and i'll be in favor of it also all
right
yeah i think but for now this planet is
the spaceship that we have
yeah as you said and um
and and really you know it's the theme
of ours that
here this is the spaceship that we have
all of the people are on it and failure
is not an option
all right that is a that's an excellent
place to end on then
uh i think both you and i share the
science fiction geek gene uh about about
getting to mars but we'll have to
we'll have to potentially delay that
until we figure out
uh climate change but hopefully we get
to that
so yeah thanks so much for coming on um
this has been
really interesting i feel like i learned
a lot of new things this is there's a
lot here that
i think probably most people who are
even
fairly familiar with with climate
science aren't familiar with
so i just want to offer you a
final little space here if you have any
final remarks or
any anything you'd like to say that you
feel like is
unresolved or unsaid just any last words
for listeners
um well for those people who've made it
through the entire podcast
thank you for listening and being so
engaged and interested in the topic
um i think that apart from the things we
talked about previously
it's heartening and important that
people from other fields
are paying attention to the climate
problem and becoming engaged
particularly people from the technology
sector and certain parts of industry
that bring a way of thinking about
problems that's useful
so um i think there are probably
lots of people in your community who you
know may be turning their attention to
this or turning their attention this
more fully
um in a new way and may have
perspectives
and ideas and resources that are useful
to bring to it
the field has been quite academic
more academic than many other fields of
endeavor
and so i think you know what
what people in silicon valley think
about in terms of
you know how how you might transform a
sector quickly
or problem quickly is
you know presents an opportunity and so
i hope that people are inspired to
become involved and
um you know and become involved in the
parts of the space that are
you know maybe more controversial or
or you know easier for people like us to
think about
all right and and so if if people want
to
to follow or find you or check out
silver lining
where the best places to to get more
information or
see what those are up to so i'm on
linkedin and twitter is at kelley
wandser
and um our website is silverlining.ngo
silver lining all one word no s at the
end
dot ngo and you can find uh
the majority of the information about
what we do is there
and feel free to reach out to me on
linkedin or
on twitter and uh or contact lucas who
can contact me
yeah all right wonderful thanks so much
kelly all right thanks very much lucas i
appreciate it
uh thanks for taking so much time yeah
you too no
thank you all right